it was yesterday yesterday around this
time we got a hold of Pat 40 Yahoo
Sports covers college football college
basketball lives in Louisville he was on
campus a stake out there outside the
administration office waiting for Rick
Pitino to show up and find out his fate
pretty brisk 24 hours there Pat yeah you
think the news cycle is moving with
great rapidity here and yes shortly
after I hung up with you Dan
Tom George came and went five-minute
meeting with the president an hour later
Rick Pitino came and went
five-minute meeting with the president
and now both of them probably will never
do another day's work at the University
of Louisville and Pitino is gonna fight
this but how does he fight this and any
way he can save his job or is this just
saving his legacy he can try to find it
I'd to me it's a complete losing cause
to me quite frankly I think it takes a
lot of gall if he's going to fight for
his buyout which is a Monstress buyout
reportedly but if after the position
that he has put himself in the
basketball program in here I I'm not
sure really what the argument would be
other than the fact that he's not a guy
that's accustomed to losing and backing
down so you know I I think he will try
but I just don't see any way how
eventually at least he's not fired with
cause and a lot of that money is taken
away from him how big does this get huge
I don't think there's any doubt about it
I mean as it all blew up Tuesday went on
that night Tuesday night and at four
minutes the devil investigator said to
me said well get ready tomorrow that's
Nike day and lo and behold there's FBI
subpoenas for the Nike grassroots
basketball operation and so now we've
got deep two of the three major food
shoe Giants that are in the crosshairs
of this talked to an assistant coach who
said he thinks there could end up being
a hundred coaches answering questions
about this hole before it's done and I
mean you're pulling back a rug and you
are looking at everybody who recruits
even you know three-star and up players
and what's the involvement of shoe
companies in that and where's where's
the involvement of agents and financial
advisors
I'm wondering about Pacino this you know
this plausibility of you know
deniability or how if if that's even the
way to say it but can he go in and say I
just didn't know I didn't know there's
gone which I said if even if he says
that it that's his defense I fire him
that he that he didn't know this after
what happened with the the strippers can
that be what his defense is I simply did
not know this was going on it's not it's
not a plausible defense it's really not
if you may say plausible deniability but
it's implausible for sustainable
employment he played the I didn't know
card once you only get one of those in a
career you can't do that again and a you
know especially look if all people like
me and and reporters say they cover the
game know that this is how the system
works you don't think that a Hall of
Fame basketball coach who's been inside
of it for forty years knows that this is
how the system works that he had no idea
when all of a sudden the five-star
recruit top ten guy who has been weirdly
flirting around with different programs
suddenly just shows up and says I want
to go to Louisville that doesn't set off
any alarm bells at all I think maybe it
should have the death penalty keeps
coming up that you've had a repeat
offender brazen and what they were doing
right in the faces of you know the
n-c-double-a investigation but this is
bad for business for the ACC and I said
if if this is Creighton Creighton may
get the death penalty
this is Louisville this is the ACC and I
have a hard time believing they're gonna
levy the death penalty on that
basketball program your thoughts you're
right that the ACC and the ACC's
television partners ESPN and others
would fight that very hard because it
does hurt their product their ability to
put games on television to put a marquee
program out there for consumption you
mean if you take a little basketball
literally for away for a year or two
it's it's a damaging thing for a lot
more people than just Louisville
basketball but you know I
if the NC double-a which maintains that
the death
is still part of its penalty structure
and still could be applied and enforced
if it if that's the truth then this is a
textbook definition of it and it should
be applied and enforced in my opinion
yeah but Pat if Baylor didn't get the
death penalty Louisville is not getting
the death penalty back when they had the
murdered player know everything that's
gone on at that athletic department
there yeah I mean the football stuff's
not even the n-c-double-a case yet or if
it is we don't it's not one that's
gotten the bone okay any sort of penalty
structure I know in look yes I know what
you're saying though what happened at
Baylor and what happened at Penn State
is is far beyond anything that we're
talking about Louisville buying for
basketball bucks if we knew it's weird
to me it's just those aren't
n-c-double-a issues those are law and
order matters if we knew all of this was
happening has been happening for decades
right we suspected that this was
happening we didn't know you know the
different avenues of how guys got paid
and bribed and whatever those things you
know how they took place why did why is
it now coming to light that the FBI had
to go in that the NCAA did not want to
do this well I mean that's that to me
that's one of the big questions of this
absolutely is is does this point out
that the NCAA is a complete failure and
its ability to police itself you know
that if this has been the standard way
of doing business for twenty twenty-five
years and everybody knew it and they
couldn't do a thing about it
then what does that say about the the
ability of the sport to keep itself
clean you know it's a I think a huge
repudiation of the NCAA you know how it
ended up in in the FBI's lap still not
completely sure other than somebody
probably just hand-delivered it to them
and said you know what hey if you if you
want to do this here it is and we'll
show you how it's done
but the fact that the NCAA couldn't get
it done is is I think a major part of
this whole story yeah I think the
n-c-double-a should just hire Yahoo
Sports and say would you do all of our
work for us no I'm being serious
like they outsource this
then you guys do investigative work
we'll give you the credit you help clean
up college athletics what do you think
what's their vacation policy like no I
mean I I certainly hear what you're
saying that yes this perhaps should be
outsourced to other people that have
maybe better whether it's better tools
to do it or are less encumbered because
of the inherent conflict that the NCAA
is trying to promote college athletics
and you don't want these people
investigating college athletics doing
the you know in the same time so I mean
it really it has been talked about
actually about outsourcing more to like
ex law enforcement people that sort of
thing it might be something they need
the more seriously consider Pat good to
talk to you have a great weekend and
thanks for joining us my pleasure Dan
thank you that's Pat forty one of the
great columnist covering college
athletics and a great sense of humor I
think you have to have a great sense of
humor if you're covering college
athletics now the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience